welcome everyone to the school greatest
podcast i got my man rich roll in the
studio what's up brother what's up dude
good to see you pleasure to uh hang with
my brother yeah i'm excited and you've
got a new book called the plant power
way i'm going to show the camera really
quick because this is a video podcast as
well plant power away with yourself and
your wife that's right what was it like
writing a book with your wife co-author
with my wife uh
julie's amazing julie pie is her name
yeah she uh
she brought the magic for this one yeah
i mean this is this book my first book
was a memoir so it was just me writing
it finding ultra but this one is
really a lifestyle guide kind of a
lifestyle primer as well as a cookbook
and
julie uh is a magician in the kitchen
she's an artist and she really uh
brought the heat to create something
special so yeah it was interesting you
know i'm like as a writer i like to hide
out
you know like do my thing in isolation
and this was very much a collaborative
effort not just with her but with the
whole thing
you had to work with her as opposed to
be an introvert
exactly yeah which is my default right
um but it was great you know it was uh
you know we were sort of a yin and a
yang and kind of what we brought to the
equation and i really think that that's
what is going to make it really special
i like it man and it's all uh whole food
plant-based recipes but also lifestyle
stuff as well right yeah i mean it's uh
you know i'm a plant-based guy i've been
plant-based for eight years and our
family we've got four kids and our
nephew lives with us we've got a lot of
people in our house right and uh
and you know we're a plant-based family
but this really isn't uh
it's not it's not a book for vegans it's
really oriented around just the modern
family you know it's sort of like people
that are just trying to eat a little bit
better live live a little bit better
make better choices people who don't
have the time to go online and research
nutrition you know they know like yeah i
should probably buy organic but like
does it matter and you know i've heard
of gmos but like what's the deal like we
tried to make everything really
elementary and simple and and also
create just super
delicious
food you know whether you're a vegan
whether you're a meat eater or vegan or
whatever
to be able to put really great dishes on
the table that are going to please
everybody including your kids you know
it's sort of like the question that we
get all the time is how do i get my kids
to eat healthier you know they're
they're eating macaroni and cheese and
all that kind of stuff so there's a lot
of information and kind of tips and
tools and resources to help create
healthier sustainable
trajectories because sustainability
everybody can go on a diet but like how
do you actually shift your lifestyle and
make it stick yeah i like it man and
you know for those that don't know your
story you've been on the podcast before
so we'll have that episode linked up but
for those that don't know your story if
you want to give a quick recap to how
you got into the whole plant-based
living in the first place yeah sure uh
i'm 48 years old right now um but about
eight years ago when i was 39
uh i was tipping the scales a little bit
heavy i was about 50 pounds overweight
uh working as a corporate lawyer kind of
toiling away the 80 hour work week
riding the elevator up and down and kind
of living that lifestyle and i was
having a little bit of an existential
crisis about my place in the world like
i you know i was married and i was
building family and of course i i love
them but at the same time i just felt
like i was on the wrong path
professionally and it was confusing it
was almost like vertigo because my whole
life had been premised on this idea of
you know get good grades get get into
the best college like then go to law
school and get the best law firm job and
like when you kind of you know are on
the precipice of being a partner in a
big law firm you think well i did
everything right uh this is this is what
i was promised my whole life was going
to make me happy
and i wasn't
i was not fulfilled and i looked around
me at the people i was working with and
i just didn't aspire to have any of
their lives and so i was having this
kind of
you know kind of internal crisis about
what i was doing with myself and
meanwhile i wasn't taking care of myself
i was eating
uh what i like to call the window diet
right right you can pull your car up to
a fine dining establishment roll the
window down and they hand you food
that's what you eat so i was subsisting
on you know cheeseburgers and french
fries and nachos and pizza and taco bell
and all that kind of stuff for years and
years and years and it was starting to
catch up to me you know 50 pounds
overweight and then
one night uh
shortly before my 40th birthday walking
up a simple flight of stairs i had to
pause i was winded out of breath
shortness of breath
tightness in my chest one of my brow and
i honestly thought i was having a heart
attack and i realized in that moment
that i needed to change how i was living
and that really began the journey of
exploring healthy foods and healthy
lifestyle habits um i ended up adopting
a plant-based diet which you know look
you know i'm the last person in the
world that ever thought i would go vegan
like for me like vegans are like guys
that kick the hacky sack and yeah smoke
a lot of dope and like have dreadlocks
you know which is fine that's cool that
that was that's not my trip you know so
i never identified with that
but when i started eating whole foods
plant-based foods i really started to
feel
so much better like incredibly better i
had a lot of energy too resurgence of
vitality i could have never predicted
and it really
kind of solved that equation of food as
medicine you know hippocrates said it in
340 bc and right of course i'd heard
that quote uh you know growing up but i
never really thought about it and i was
starting to realize like wow we really
can
impact
how we feel and how our bodies function
and how our minds operate and how we
interact with other people based upon
the things that we're putting in our
body right it's so elementary right but
i don't know that we really
take that um to heart enough and so
that's that's what happened to me and i
you know it's a long story and we talked
about it in the last podcast but
ultimately i ended up becoming an ultra
endurance athlete and uh i started
killing it in these crazy super
multi-day
you know double ironman distance
triathlons and
in 2010 i did something that no one else
had ever done which was do five ironman
distance triathlons on five hawaiian
islands in under a week wow so and that
kind of they take like 24 hours don't
they uh no i mean an iron man or
triathlon yeah so so a single iron man
for your listeners who might not know is
a very long triathlon which in a period
of one day you do
a 2.4 mile swim 112 mile bike and then
run a marathon so i did five of those in
a row on five different islands like
traveling you did five iron man's five
iron man's on five hawaiian islands in a
week the goal was to do it in five days
we ran into a bunch of problems and
logistical challenges and sleep
deprivation and all kinds of craziness
uh wow but we got it done and no one it
was i did it with my buddy jason lester
no one had ever tried it before
so it was it was sort of a cool kind of
thing and to do that at age i was 44 at
the time when i did that um was a really
cool thing and that's kind of like what
my first book was about kind of going
from couch potato
schlubby lawyer guy to you know
middle-aged uh ultra endurance right
why do you think uh eating a plant-based
diet is so intimidating for a lot of
people because there's this new trend
and people are going vegan and people
are starting to just live off of you
know plants but why is it so
intimidating well i think it's
intimidating for a number of reasons i
mean the first thing is is it sounds
like a huge deprivation diet like oh my
god you know how can i go a day without
eating cheese or you know how can i
you know go a day without eating a
cheeseburger and and these kinds of
foods animal products find their way
into
most of the things that people are
eating on a typical western diet um
and so i think that right off the bat
people are like whoa not so fast right
now that's kind of that's kind of scary
and by the way we've been told our whole
lives that if you want strong muscles
you need to eat you know beef is what's
for dinner and milk does a body good and
you know i certainly believed all those
things my whole life so it was really
kind of um anathema that that you could
not only like breathe air in and out of
your lungs but actually be an athlete
without eating those things uh was
something i would have never predicted
and so
you know part of my message is that uh
you know plant-based foods are
incredibly healthy and and they contain
everything that you
need to live and also you know and this
is what the plant power away is really
about is it doesn't have to be a
deprivation thing like we look at
we try to we always say
focus on all the new exciting foods um
that you're bringing into your diet like
nutrient-dense uh foods that are super
healthy for you
uh as opposed to focusing on the couple
things that you're giving out that
you're giving out right gotcha and what
would you say are the highest
performance foods out there um
interesting uh
well i think
performance from the perspective of
being an athlete
i mean just running optimally in your
life but also giving you the most energy
the most
recovery
benefits that you know whatever it may
be i think that uh making sure that
you're getting lots of dark leafy greens
into your diet you know we're all
talking about kale these days at least
in los angeles
yeah it's all about kale
so uh i always start my day with uh with
a smoothie um a blended smoothie and
like our high-powered vitamix blender
that usually contains spinach and kale
and things like that and they're so rich
in phytonutrients and micronutrients and
they just energize you they just like
instead of eating like a really heavy
like breakfast of like waffles or
something like that chicken and waffles
man it's so cute i know it is i know
look i know man
um
but to start your day by like drinking a
salad and just you can almost feel your
body coming alive you know it's it's a
it's it's a miraculous thing so i always
say to people like if you're gonna just
don't worry about vegan or plant like
you're 100 whatever just like
start drinking
blended dark leafy green smoothies in
the morning and like watch your
watch your life body change your body
change well i mean i think it's it's
your body yes it's your energy levels
but as you know uh
you know when you have good energy that
affects everything it affects how you
perceive the world it affects how you
interact with people your mood yeah your
mood stress levels ripple effect of that
applies to everything in your life yeah
that's true
what um
tell me what are a couple other foods
besides the dark
greens i like i like to eat a lot of
lentils and and beans they're very high
in protein so as an athlete that's
important of course sure um i also uh
i'm a big fan of veggie burritos that's
like my go-to lunch veggie burrito and a
pinch yeah in a pinch when you're
driving around town i can always
especially in los angeles i can always
find
uh you know rice and beans and guacamole
right right
what else i mean i'm i love super foods
there's a lot of talk about superfoods i
don't think there's any superfood that's
a panacea
and i think a lot of people want to jump
on the superfood bandwagon before
they've cleaned up their diet i look at
that as like the cherry on top of the
sundae like when you're eating super
clean then superfoods can give you that
added
that added edge so like cordyceps i love
athletic performance spirulina which is
the highest protein content by weight of
any food on the planet including really
including beef spirulina is good yeah we
could have a whole podcast about super
foods but wow next time the next book
um okay so juice versus um
non-juice is it better to juice your
salad or blend yourself i like juices
versus blending yeah we get that
question a lot too and i think uh they
both have their place you know i think
that if you're what if you're blending
your drink like you're putting you're
putting all that you're packing all
these foods you know beets spinach kale
hemp seeds flax seed you know all these
kinds of things into a blender and
you're you're blending it down into a
drinkable form so you're getting all the
fiber you're getting like all the
nutrients they can be very calorie dense
because you're getting the entire food
in there right they're almost like an
incredibly
super packed nutrient-dense meal sure a
juice extracts the fiber from the food
from the fruit or the vegetable
so it's a very highly concentrated dose
of phytonutrients and i look at juicing
more as medicinal you know i think you
got to be careful with juices especially
when juices are very high in fruit
because the sugar content can be super
high so they both have their place they
just have different purposes gotcha but
you shouldn't you're saying you
shouldn't have like a bunch of juices
every day or you shouldn't just live off
of a juice down well i think it depends
on what kind of like if it's just pure
if it's pure klg you know as opposed to
orange juice you know and i think
there's also a difference between
you know the kind of juices that you'll
see in los angeles that like creation
juice or you know blueprint juices these
very high kind of like you know
artisanal you know organic juices that
can be very expensive you can make them
at home for super cheap with your own
with your own juicer
um
so i think it depends on what kind but i
think you do have to be a little bit
more cautious about just you know
pounding juices all day long gotcha okay
cool
um so let's say you know i'm surrounded
by a lot of healthy athletes
all over the place i work out with
healthy guys who are shredded six packs
you know ripped
super high energy throughout the day who
aren't vegan who aren't plant-based
right so why should someone who is
already super healthy consider a
plant-based diet yeah that's a great
question and the first thing i would say
is like if it's not broke why fix it
yeah i mean the first thing i would say
is i'm not here to tell anybody what
they should or they shouldn't eat that's
everybody's own personal choice i'm here
to share my experience and how you know
my life had changed by adopting a
plant-based diet so that's the first
thing so yeah i'm not here to
proselytize any one perspective on the
other end i think everybody's different
and the first person to recognize that
the second thing i would say is that
just because you're shredded doesn't
mean that you're healthy you can look
super fit you know like it's it's
surprising actually if you look at
professional athletes and start to talk
to them about what they're actually
eating like there's still a long way to
go in terms of yeah so i look at it in
terms of long-term lifestyle and health
and longevity especially as i start to
get older
if somebody's feeling super great
you know i'm not going to tell them they
need to change what they're doing
and i would say that it's not that
eating a plant-based diet will
inherently make you a better athlete but
i will say this and this has been my
experience
that the typical western diet or a diet
i should say that is sort of high in
animal products dairy and processed
foods which is becoming a bigger and
bigger problem obviously tends to be
very acid forming on the body and we
have to work very hard to maintain an
essentially neutral ph in our body like
our
all of our systems try to regulate you
know our ph to keep it in neutral and
the air that we breathe the amount of
sleep that we get the amount of stress
in our lives and particularly the foods
that we eat can influence that ph and so
when you're eating a diet that has a lot
of processed foods and a lot of animal
products in dairy that's very acid
forming and then the body has to work go
into hyperdrive to bring the ph back to
neutral and to do that it has to leach
minerals out of the bones and it
produces a lot of inflammation and as
you know as an athlete
inflammation impedes recovery
so uh the quicker you can recover in
between workouts the harder you can go
you can go the longer you can go the
less likely you are to get injured the
less likely you are to over train to you
know miss workouts so it's not that
overnight you're a better athlete but
when you protract that out over a course
of a number of seasons or years you're
going to realize tremendous performance
gains by eating a very uh like
anti-inflammatory diet or a more
alkaline forming diet and plant-based
foods on the on the whole on the average
i mean there's certainly there are
plant-based foods that are acid forming
but on the whole it's very alkaline
forming and very anti-inflammatory sure
so that's allowed me
to go i mean when i trained for my first
ultraman which is a double ironman race
that it's like a 320 mile
triathlon that circumnavigates the big
island of hawaii the first time that i
attempted it was in 2008 and i really
only had seven months to prepare for it
and i really think that i was able to
drop all the weight and go from
essentially a couch potato guy to
ultraman in such a short period of time
is because i was eating in this
particular fashion completely cut
everything out all dairy i mean all meat
products all meat products all dairy uh
and essentially all processed foods i
mean i would eat you know coconut oil
and olive oil and things like that are
are technically processed foods right
you know trying to reduce as much as
possible the extent to which any of the
foods i was eating was processed okay
if you could uh go back um and tell your
pre-vegan self one thing about health
that from all that you know now what
would you tell that person um
one thing about health
or a couple things
for all the information you know now and
you can go
and talk to that guy
you know five years before he's he
stopped eating all the bad foods what
would you say that you know about health
i think the biggest thing is is is a
very general thing which is that we all
have so much greater control over our
health than we've than we're then we
sort of walk around believing like we
sort of um abdicate our health choices
to our doctor and we think that our
doctors know everything and you know the
truth is is that you know really in
medical school they don't really teach
nutrition it's like an elective course
most of them don't know any more about
nutrition than the average person who
spends a little bit of time researching
it sure
and my my my call to action really is to
take control of that decision-making
process for yourself and understand
that uh that you can dictate um
your longevity and your emotional state
and your physical state by making better
choices and not just by doing it in a
short-term way but doing it in a way
that works within the construct of your
life so that it's sustainable and i
think that um
that uh
that
what was i gonna say i lost my train of
thought um simply the idea that uh
i know what i was gonna say that there's
a lot of people that walk around they're
in poor health and they go well it's
genetics you know i'm genetically
disposed to to have this or to be like
this and so they take a medication and
you know our doctor told me i need to
take statins yeah and and what i think
most people don't realize is that these
medications are not curing their
ailments they're just they're basically
taking care of the symptoms so that
people can walk around and not have to
think about what actually led to this
problem
so it's about getting back to
um really healing yourselves and being
preventive in your approach to health so
that you don't get into that situation
to begin with and to understand that you
can reverse so many conditions i mean
right now louis we're in this crazy
uh time uh where people like you and i
are super into health and we like to
talk about it we have audiences that
that enjoy hearing about it but the
truth is
is that um we've never been more sick as
a society one out of every three people
will die of a heart attack wow 70 of
americans are obese or overweight and by
2030 70 70
oh my gosh and by 2030 50 of americans
will be diabetic or pre-diabetic like
that's crazy
that's crazy unless we do something
about it and the greatest irony in all
of this is that 80 to 90
of chronic illnesses like those and
others
are reversible or preventable reversible
through simple diet and lifestyle
alterations that we can control these
things if these are reversible and
preventable then why aren't doctors
educated on food as medicine and why
aren't they being you know why isn't
this a mandatory
lessons that they need to learn in
school as like you know a serious thing
that they need to be educated on you're
appreciative of the choir i mean i don't
get it part of this is part of why just
drugs yes this is part of my advocacy
and and part of my mission is to help uh
you know make that
that be the protocol you know and there
are amazing doctors out there right now
who are doing incredible work doctors
like neil barnhart and dr esselstyn and
dr dean ornish and and many many years
of rankings
she's amazing yeah there's there's there
are there is a a trend and i think the
the reason why it doesn't exist right
now is
purely uh
economics you know right now and
especially in terms of big medicine and
big pharma and kind of how research gets
funded like there if there's not some ip
at the end of this road that we can
patent and sell as a drug
who's going to throw a ton of money at
uh you know trying to figure out if
broccoli is good for you like there's
there's no money to be made by that so
we need to rethink our whole process of
medical education and it really does
need to get prioritized to be on
functional medicine and preventive
medicine and you're starting to see it
changes at the beginning of so it's an
exciting time
and i guess you know the
pharmaceutical companies can't make
money unless people are sick
right everyone's healthy they're broke
right and and if you talk to a doctor
there's a lot of pressure for them to
see as many patients a day and to just
diagnose and prevent prescribe you know
and that's that's it's not that they're
they're not bad people they're they got
into medicine because they want to help
people but they have bills to pay and
this is just kind of the way it's set up
and i so so i think that you know unless
you're an outlier unless you're someone
like frank lippman who's trying to
create you know these functional
medicine clinics and do something a
little bit different it's very difficult
so it's a systemic problem that we need
to look at what can
the average person do about that to
support
they can start to uh tend to themselves
in a mind-body spirit way you know they
can start to explore things like
meditation and yoga and healthy eating
and
functional movement and functional body
strength like all of these things are
important it's not just you know
health begins and ends with what's on
your plate you know there's nothing more
powerful that you can do to change how
you feel about yourself than what you're
eating right but i think that's just the
beginning you know there's a whole um
pantheon of lifestyle practices that you
know i'm continuing to learn about and
explore that are improving my life
what's the things you're learning lately
well meditation for me has been the
biggest like watershed past year and you
know i've been meditating on and off for
the better part of 17 years but i've
always struggled with trying to find a
way to make it stick and be consistent
about it and the busier i get the more
difficult it is to kind of the more
conversations and excuses you come up
with of course you know and like look
you know i got a bunch of kids i got i
got a lot of stuff you got four or five
kids four kids and my nephew lives
without yeah like we got there's a lot
of energy in my house yeah yeah so it's
very easy for me to say i don't have
time but what i found i've really made
it a priority this year to do it every
morning and so what's your daily ritual
looks like so 20 minutes in the morning
without fail
uh and it's it's a it's a simple breath
practice and i've been playing around
with the headspace app which has really
helped me a lot i have that but i
haven't used it yet yeah it's great
because it just kind of it's a i have it
right on my iphone you know what i did i
put it down on the the dock at the
bottom is one of the four main apps so i
always see it and uh and it's just it's
it you know i like i like the the
practices that they offer on the app
they're very um accessible and and
there's not a lot of woo in it andy put
a comb who who is the guy behind
headspace
records all of the um
all of the meditation programs on there
and they're they're very easy to follow
it just makes it easy and like it holds
me accountable so i think accountability
is a huge thing with with changing
lifestyle practices and so yeah there
you go that's basically yeah but you
haven't logged in yet you guys got it
you gotta like create your account you
got the app that you haven't used i
never used anything yet uh yeah it's
like anything like i have it so i think
that i'm doing it but i'm actually not
doing it well i actually do a pretty
good you know meditation for i think
it's about 12 minutes in the morning and
then at night but so you do 20 minutes
using headspace yeah it's just a guided
meditation basically it's a guided
meditation yeah it's breathing it's
breath there's some visualization and
they have all different kinds of
programs depending upon you know what
you like if you want to if you're having
problems with stress or sleep or
whatever you can pick choose but the
point really is just that you're doing
it not that you're adhering to so i
think a lot of people are like well i
need to i need to this the perfect
practice i need this to be right it's
the same thing with exercise well i
can't go out and run until i have the
perfect pair of running shoes these are
all like barriers and excuses to
actually just doing it and i've just
noticed that
um it really has uh improved my life in
every single way by just making it cons
consistency is king in the last year you
started this right 20 minutes in the
morning what's the biggest benefits
you've seen since doing this um
being able to
navigate through a lot of uh
stimuli coming at me you know like
yourself like i'm sure you get a million
emails and you're like you're doing all
these podcasts and you're you're
juggling a lot of different things
you're writing a book like these are all
things that i'm doing as well and it's
very very easy for me to get overwhelmed
and stressed and stressed and then and
then i'm not productive because when i'm
doing one thing i'm thinking about the
other thing that i'm not doing and it's
allowed me to just ground myself and
just
um focus better and be able to
navigate relationships phone calls
emails and all that that kind of thing
with um a little bit more
grace and ease right and and just
my interactions with people are better
i'm more present i'm more focused and as
a result like that 20 minutes that i
spend in the morning turns into you know
maybe two hours of save time because i'm
more productive throughout the day let's
talk about presence how many uh how does
food affect our presence during the day
and how present we are in moments
a lot you know i think that uh and is
there research backing this well i mean
look let's let's just talk about
anecdotal research like if you go out
and eat like a heavy lunch like what
how's the house you know from food coma
yeah you're like you're down and out for
a good 90 minutes
yeah
so what if you could eat something for
lunch that would actually make you feel
better after you ate it than before you
ate it it's important to come back and
and and really and just hammer for the
next two hours and get a bunch of stuff
done rather than then like kind of be
like sleepwalking for a little bit so
you know there you go you don't need any
more than that for me but i think also
um you know having maintaining a high
level of energy throughout the day so
you don't have these peaks and valleys
like look man you throw down a monster
drink or a red bull and
smoke a cigarette and then you know like
you're up and down you're bouncing off
the walls you're crashing you're high
you're all these different things but
just to be able to acclimate to just a
you know
uh just a really solid good level of
energy that's consistent from the moment
you wake up in the morning to the moment
get out of bed i like it man what other
rituals are you doing besides meditating
in the morning meditating in the morning
do you cook all your own foods or do you
go out and eat uh you know plant-based
foods orders a little bit of both i mean
usually we cook at home and you know my
wife is the artist because she's got
kids yeah she's got a cookie
she gets all the credit for the cooking
she's unbelievable her food is so
unknown i mean this is all her food on
the couch yeah these are all that's the
other thing with this book like we
didn't go out and hire some chef to like
create recipes for
for uh
you know to create a book these are all
very authentic to the way we live to the
food that we give our kids and you know
my wife really is quite the genius of
that so right right so usually we're
eating at home and what we do is we make
we make uh
we make a priority out of the family
meal it's a ritual we involve all the
kids in it and it's you know it's
getting back to
um
you know the beauty and um
just the value of
sharing that time together the process
of making the meal
yeah making it into a thing and and when
you look at
the cultures that uh have the most
longevity have you heard of the blue
zones book yes okay so dan buettner
who's the guy behind the blue zones he's
a a national geographic fellow he's a
friend you should have him on the
podcast yeah it's like the happiest
people in the world
i'll hook you up he's gonna be great
he's amazing
um and he went around the world and
studied where are the people the
happiest and where do they live the
longest yeah and from that he extracted
um and he found these blue zones across
the world like okinawa and ikaria which
is an island in the aegean japan right
yeah that's okinawa
and you know a bunch of other like sort
of remote places and he went to these
cultures and he studied them and he said
what are they doing that we're not doing
isn't there one in like north carolina
as well or something or there's one no
there's one in loma linda in southern
california yeah yeah that's a blue zone
it's a blue zone because
um because it's all vegan yeah they all
they all eat that's a big part of it
well it's very it's a it's a um it's a
religious community and and they all eat
plant-based they live based on the
principles in the but there's some
there's a passage in the bible that
basically says you should eat plants
from the i don't know exactly what it
goes but yeah um and they and they're a
very tight-knit community and they're
very family oriented so he kind of
divined these principles out of these
cultures and
and you know eating predominantly
plant-based food was a big part of it
but also
like respecting your elders and keeping
them around and creating community and
and really keeping the family tight and
the family meal is a big part of that so
we try to practice that in what we're
doing but we eat out my son my oldest
son tyler it was his 20th birthday
last night so we went to gracias madre
which
it's the best right it's so good it's
like you know we're in this time right
now where
where people are are understanding you
know the beauty and the power of eating
plant-based or mostly plant-based and
there are restaurants cropping up uh
gracias madre is one of them
it's a completely yeah crossroads is
unbelievable so good they're they're
plant-based restaurants but they don't
advertise as being vegan they just have
better foods so good you know crossroads
is probably the best restaurant in l.a
it's amazing you know i go there is a
genius who's the chef there so good
so that's the way that you are
ultimately going to get people to shift
their lifestyle habits to eating better
is by making the food just taste better
yeah
not one there's not one thing place
where it says this is a plant-based
restaurant it's a vegan restaurant they
just give you amazing food that's
delicious so good and you're like oh
that didn't have meat in it that didn't
have dairy in it i would have never
known
i went to uh i mean i don't know if you
know bill glaser but he's a friend of
mine i think you've connected the email
yeah yeah and he takes me to a
crossroads that's like the only place he
want to go out together and be with mary
to eat and we went to have brunch one
time for like sunday brunch and the
chicken and waffles was unbelievable man
i was like i could eat this you know
every sunday it was so good not only
that like if you're visiting la and you
want to see movie stars oh they're
everyone's
constantly there yeah constantly
that's crazy
um
you talk about cooking being an art form
what's that all about
i think that
that cooking and this is this is a
better question for julie a great guest
you should have her on too um she you
know she's an artist she's a painter
she's a sculptor she's a musician and
she approached food just as any other
medium it's an immediate it's a medium
to express yourself it looks like art
you know yeah
looks like
and when you approach food from that
perspective of what can i create what
how can i combine these things to create
something different and new new and how
can i infuse this with my love like my
positive energy
to then you know deliver to somebody
else in service to say please enjoy this
that's a beautiful secret thing you know
and i think that's something that we
should honor and take seriously as
opposed to just trying to whip something
up quickly yeah instead make it like a
hobby something fun this crazy
convenience lifestyle where everything
is about speed and how fast i can eat
and we and we're just eating on the go
you know and there's really something to
be said
uh to just stopping and saying let's
really be grateful for what we have in
front of us the blessings that we have i
mean look at the world that we live in i
mean we're so lucky man it's amazing
we're so lucky human beings have never
you know in the history of humankind
like we've never had it so good it's
amazing and yet we walk around resentful
and we're pissed off because this guy
didn't call us back or whatever it is
you know
just to like stop and say you know for
right now this is what we're doing yeah
and let's just be
present with it i like it
you talk about in the book the three
lifestyle paths to living
plant-powered
and it's vitality performance and
transformation can you talk about those
yes so throughout the book i mean
you know
it is a cookbook there's 120 plus
recipes in there whatever but but really
the the the
the um
what distinguishes it i think is really
all the lifestyle guidance and so
throughout the book we've created three
lifestyle paths for people that are kind
of new to this idea like well i've never
really thought about you know eating
plants and
you know i don't
and we wanted to create three programs
based upon
um you know what your interest might be
like if it's a guy like you lewis you're
an athlete you don't really need to lose
weight but performance is what's going
to motivate you so this is a guide that
will kind of key code throughout the
book
um the recipes that you're going to want
to pay most attention to and we have
kind of a day in the life here's a
typical
here's a typical way of eating and
conducting yourself throughout the day
that includes meditation in the morning
that's going to help you unlock
your inner potential that might still be
a little bit dormant because you haven't
quite explored foods to the extent that
maybe you should and then the other ones
transformation is for people that really
need a complete
whole reboot to their life like maybe
they're super overweight or they've been
sick years ago yeah exactly and they're
like ready to just go full bore and do
it hardcore because they want to they
want the whole shebang and they need it
because they're they're at a place in
their life where they're ready they're
willing to make that kind of a sacrifice
and a change their life depends on it
otherwise i'm gonna have a heart attack
at some point right
and then the other one is just for
really living uh
sustainably and more balanced yeah
and
so it's not you know it's not for
anything super dramatic on either side
of it it's just like i want to be
more balanced than i am and you know i
think a big part of the book and a focus
of it too that we haven't really touched
on is sustainability um sustainability
in healthy lifestyle practices and
eating practice practices but also kind
of getting out of ourselves and our
selfish concerns about how we feel and
and and really contemplating uh what's
most sustainable for the planet because
and that's when you look at that
well
you know when we everybody wants to be a
good environmentalist right like you
know maybe i shouldn't use so much gas i
should ride my bike and we recycle we're
doing all these things now to kind of be
better citizens than maybe we were 30
years ago right
but there's a lot of stuff that i think
people don't realize and when you kind
of take a look at
how we produce food to arrive on our
plates it's it's quite eye-opening um
you know uh when you look at animal
agriculture just the business of raising
animals for food
it's incredibly wasteful and crazy
it exerts an extraordinary toll on the
planet so we all look at like fracking
and um and you know the extent to which
we're dependent upon fossil fuels but
the truth is that animal agriculture is
far more detrimental to the planet than
i think it's like uh animal agriculture
accounts for
uh something like 13 or 18
of all greenhouse gas emissions which is
more than all of transportation combined
and then you look at it when you look at
um the extent to which
the rain forests are being destroyed the
amount of water use it takes 660 gallons
of water to produce one hamburger like
if you're just an economic an economist
and you look at this you're like this is
crazy this doesn't make any sense like
we're wasting
so many resources to take this little
animal and blow it up into a huge animal
that we can eat for food um
and you know the runoff the the methane
everything you know it's it's it's
basically creating species alcohol
blooms in our oceans
where no life can live and really it's
it's really insane there's a movie that
i'm involved with called
cowspiracy it's documentary that takes a
look at um what animal agriculture is
really doing to our planet it's going to
be coming out
this spring on netflix and look for that
which is really it's really quite
amazing when you look into that and so
what what what my message is and what
the books messages is like let's be a
little more conscious of our choices
like it's not just about what i need or
what i want or what tastes good like we
have a greater responsibility to sure
our planet and i think we all need to
kind of really honor that a little bit
more yeah so you're not telling people
you have to eat vegan plant-based but if
you're going to choose meat be conscious
about it and eat in a sustainable way
the best way possible yeah i mean i
think we all have a responsibility to
try to uh increase the extent to which
we're living sustainably right i like
that
a couple questions left uh what are you
most grateful for rich
what am i most grateful for the moment
right now
i like it you know what about your life
recently yes
i am uh
well i'm really grateful to
be living
my authentic truth
and i'm very grateful that
um as a result of some things i've been
working on very hard
that
that i found an audience that cares
about these things and i really do think
it's making a difference so i'm grateful
to have found a way to be of service you
know and i find a lot of gratitude
in service um
and i was reflecting as i was driving
over here about the first time that we
sat down for our podcast yeah and it was
almost two years ago and i remember
coming into your apartment here
and you had a [ __ ] you got a crappy
little you had a crappy little mic you
know and i started i had a little bit of
table start on you yeah i was like come
on man let's get you a good mic you know
let's sort you out
and then to see uh where you are now
like i'm just i'm so proud of you and i
just marvel at what you've been able to
do uh with this show and all the things
you're doing and i think that that
you know when i look at you
and i think about other people that are
trying to make a difference
i think about what they're doing but
more importantly
how they're doing it
and why they're doing it you know
because i think the how and the y
is
just as important if not more important
than the what yeah and i really respect
the how and the why of what you're doing
and i couldn't be happier for you for
the growth
um and so when in my practices whether
it's through my podcast or the books
that i'm writing and the public speaking
and all of that i'm always thinking
about
the the how how am i doing this i know
what i'm doing but how am i doing it
and always bringing it back to the why
and the why always comes back to
service and the more grounded i am
in service and genuinely honestly
being in that place of just wanting to
help and serve
then my life flourishes around that and
and that's been a very powerful
lesson and experience for me so i'm
grateful that i understand that and i
have no complaints in my in in my life
my health is good i have beautiful
children i'm happily married like i'm
living a
miraculous life and there have been
plenty of times in my life where you
know i didn't think i was gonna make it
you know i'm a recovering drug out drug
addict an alcoholic had some very dark
moments in my life and and
the idea that that
you know even several years ago that i
would be sitting here talking to you
about you know passion and living your
best life and all of these things would
have just sounded insane so i'm just
grateful to be here i love that
what
in 50 years from now or maybe 100 years
because you're going to be living that
long with a plant-based diet
what do you want people to say about you
uh
and what would better than that what
would you like to have accomplished in
the world
i would like to look back in my old age
and
and see that i've made a difference a
difference in the quality of people's
lives
not just in the foods that they're
eating but
in their perspective on their own lives
with respect to health mental health
emotional health spiritual health
physical health
and to help people understand that
no matter what their circumstance
irrespective of age or circumstance
that there is always a better healthier
more authentic version of themselves
inside of them
that can be unleashed you know and i
know that's
consistent with your message as well and
i think that we
you know we live in such a fast-paced
world and we walk around with blinders
on and we're just on autopilot and just
to be able to inspire people
to stop for a moment and reflect on
their lives and
do that inside work so that they can
truly be living the life that they're
meant to live because i think
we all have something to offer and we
all have something to that we can that
we can use to be of service to other
people and that doesn't mean you're
going to be you know
manny pacquiao or whatever but you have
your own version of that you know and to
the extent that i can help people
cultivate and express that that would
make me happy and i think 100 years from
now unless we make some serious changes
in the way this planet is operating
louis we're all going to be plant-based
right because we just can't
continue to feed the people
the number of people that we have on
this planet the way that we've been
doing it we just can't do it yeah and
the population is get on board now yeah
get used to it now yeah i like it well i
want to acknowledge you for two things i
didn't get to do this last podcast so
the first thing is
i acknowledge you for
seeing
where your health and your life was
going
downhill and having the courage to make
the change because that's probably the
hardest thing is to make that drastic
change and you went cold turkey on
everything because you knew that you
needed to have a better life for
yourself and your family and for the
people that depended on you so i
acknowledge you for first making that
change years ago the second thing i
acknowledge you for rich is
your commitment to serving others and
teaching them everything that you've
learned you're like so dedicated to this
and you travel all over the world and
you teach people you write the content
you do the research you're doing a lot
of hard work
to educate people like me and other
people who need this information so
i acknowledge you for being a symbol of
inspiration for so many people who need
this and uh it's an honor to be able to
interview you and be your friends so
thank you for what you're doing i
appreciate that yeah thank you so much
of course and like i said uh
i'm so happy to see you thriving and and
growing in the way that you are and and
i think that your advocacy is something
to marvel at and i can't wait to see
where you're headed because i know the
sky's the limit with you man i'm just
latching my train on years
it's gonna be fun we're both doing we're
both doing great it's gonna be fun
uh final question i've asked you before
what's your definition of greatness my
definition of greatness i can't i knew
you know i was driving i was like i know
he's gonna ask i should probably think
about that and i can't even remember
what i said last night but i will say
this
i think the definite my definition of
greatness
is um
when
your purpose
and your actions
and your values
are in perfect alignment
when you are truly
blazing your authentic path
in service to other people
the legend of rich roll thanks for
coming on man thanks for having me man
hi i'm lewis howes i'm an author speaker
and entrepreneur i used to be a
professional athlete
[Music]
i broke my wrist one injury was all gone
in a second it was extremely painful it
was extremely depressing this is the
biggest kind of game changer in my life
getting injured losing my passion my
ability to do what i wanted when i
wanted and how i wanted to do it